elle a désormais pignon sur rue dans
l'univers du livre elle la bd s'est même
fait une place au soleil dans les rayons
rien que pour cette année on dénombre
entre 5 et 6000 nouveautés sur le marché
c'est une immersion dans le monde du 9e
art à l'échelle régionale
une histoire de bulles normande en
quatre épisodes
un petit coin de campagne dans le bessin
voilà quelques années maintenant que
jean blaise djian trouve l'inspiration
loin bien loin de l'agitation urbaine
j'ai besoin de concentration aussi pour
eux parce que souvent je dois mettre
dans la peau de chacun des personnages
pour trouver des dialogues qui
correspondent à la personnalité de
chacun à la situation chacun ce qui fait
que bon bah je suis obligé quand même de
d'être à fond sur ce que je fais voilà c
c'est juste un inconfort la terre
d'adoption
au fil du temps la normandie est devenu
pour ce scénariste de bande dessinée un
véritable champ d'investigation mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup on est
beaucoup à raconter
l'an dernier j'ai fait une bande
dessinée sur le mont saint michel avec
tout le côté historique côté aventure
policiers mais voilà j'ai fait une bande
dessinée policière qui se passe au havre
pour retranscrire un peu les ambiances
du port la nuit tout ça il ya beaucoup à
faire sur la normandie normandy sommes
entre fiction et réalité
cette série sur l'histoire du
débarquement mettons en exergue
l'importance du travail de recherche
lorsqu'on est auteur de bd alors
normandie juin 44 n'a comment on avait
commencé ça il doit y avoir 7-8 ans et
l'idée c est tout de suite apparu avec
pascale daniel éditeur de l'époque de
faire cinq albums un pour chaque plage
de débarquement en cas chaque fois je
j'ai travaillé le scénario avec des
spécialistes des historiens ou des
guides conférenciers du guide de musée
etc
chaque album nécessité pratiquement un
an de travail surtout pour le
dessinateur mais quand même peu le
scénario a demandé beaucoup de temps
aussi pour pour pouvoir bien planté les
choses et derrière chaque album se cache
souvent l'histoire d'une complicité
entre un scénariste et un dessinateur
travail
c'est le cas pour jean blaise djian
étiez co qui avaient travaillé ensemble
sur le troisième tome de normandie juin
44 toutes les planches son dessin est
parfait c'est un dessin réaliste et ça
devient rare mais je savais aussi que
thierry n'était pas un grand amateur du
xxème siècle en dessin mais je me suis
dit que peut-être que ce sera un
challenge et puis finalement il a
accepté
c'était parfait une bande dessinée c'est
ça en racontera une histoire si
l'histoire est pas bonne on aura beau
faire le plus beau dessin du monde saura
pas grand intérêt
c'est en fait à chacun sa date à l'autre
c'est c'est une espèce de communion
quelque part entre en un scénariste et
un dessinateur parce que sinon ce serait
très difficile de travailler ensemble
mais il ya des jeux c'est que des fois
les scénaristes ont des visions qui sont
très difficiles à dessiner voire
impossible donc nous du côté dessinateur
on est obligé d'apporter soient les
solutions soit modifié quelque peu
certaines séquences de scénario pour
pouvoir s'adapter à un dessin et fasse
qu en faire en sorte que ça soit lisible
aujourd'hui l'un comme l'autre travaille
sur des projets différents
en attendant la parution prochaine de
leurs ouvrages respectifs
car une fois le travail d'ancrage
terminé les planches finit souvent sur
la table d'une maison d'édition
ce sera le prochain épisode de notre
histoire débile normande
[Musique]
ce